[Música]
Pedro Castillo fue destituido del cargo
de presidente de Perú y estaba custodia
policial por ciento un voto es el
Congreso aprobó la moción de censura que
puso fin a su mandato un hecho que tuvo
lugar solo horas después de que el mismo
Castillo anunciara la disolución del
legislativo peruano
a 16 años de cárcel fueron condenados el
expresidente de Guatemala Otto Pérez
Molina y la expicepresidenta Roxana
valdetti ambos estaban acusados de
delitos de asociación ilícita y
defraudación aduanera en el marco de un
caso de corrupción conocido como la
línea
y comenzó oficialmente en Montreal
Canadá la conferencia de Naciones Unidas
sobre biodiversidad cop 15 el encuentro
tiene como meta concretar un acuerdo
histórico entre los 190 países
asistentes para salvar especies y
ecosistemas de un daño Irreversible
Tenemos reporte
Bienvenidos a este informativo de Franz
24 en el que hacemos énfasis en las
noticias más destacadas del continente
americano solamente 16 meses estuvo
Pedro Castillo como presidente de Perú
El Ahora exmandatario fue destituido por
el congreso horas después de que
anunciara la disolución del legislativo
Castillo se encuentra ahora detenido por
las autoridades que ya han comenzado
diligencias preliminares por presunta
comisión de los delitos de rebelión y
conspiración Francisco Zacarías desde
Lima nos da más información
abogada de 60 años se convierte en la
primera mujer presidente en la historia
del Perú tras asumir el cargo pidió una
tregua política y convocó a la más
amplia unidad de todos los peruanos
dependerá de los acuerdos y las alianzas
políticas que puede establecer construir
un gobierno de ancha base que se espera
culmine en el 2026 José almagro
secretario general de la oea felicitó a
boluarte como nueva gobernante del Perú
en reemplazo de Pedro Castillo aquí en
reglamento destituyó mediante un proceso
de vacancia presidencial por haber
anunciado el cierre del congreso para
muchos Esto fue un autogolpe de estado
es por eso que la defensoría del pueblo
de este país pidió a la fiscalía iniciar
acciones penales contra Pedro Castillo
el ex gobernante se encuentra detenido
en la prefectura de Lima y ve un
panorama sombrío porque la justicia lo
procesará por el delito de rebelión por
el que según algunos juristas podría ser
deshabilitado hasta por diez años
dependerá de la fiscalía si solicite una
prisión preventiva por este caso y por
las seis acusaciones de presunta
corrupción que arrastra Castillo
Mientras tanto Dina boluarte se
encuentra aquí en Palacio de Gobierno
tratando de armar un nuevo equipo de
gobierno boluarte también cuenta con
investigaciones en el congreso por el
presunto delito de tráfico de
influencias que se encuentra congelado
en el parlamento algunos analistas
señalan que quizás más adelante el
congreso le termina aplicando un proceso
de vacancia presidencial Es una
posibilidad que sólo el tiempo lo dirá
y tras el anuncio del cierre del
Congreso y la destitución de Pedro
Castillo varios grupos de simpatizantes
y también detractores del ex mandatario
se enfrentaron en las calles los choques
tuvieron lugar en el centro de Lima
frente al lugar donde permanece detenido
Castillo ante el aumento de los
enfrentamientos la Policía Nacional de
Perú intervino usando gases lacrimógenos
para dispersar a los manifestantes y
para dispersar también los choques tanto
las autoridades como los medios de
comunicación locales no han reportado
incidentes mayores en otras ciudades del
país
correctamente y los hechos en Perú han
tenido eco no solamente en la región de
América Latina sino también en
organismos internacionales y en otros
lugares del planeta el mundo entero
sigue con atención el desarrollo de la
situación política en Perú por ejemplo
la Organización de Estados Americanos
oea que envió recientemente una
delegación a Perú para ver de primera
mano la situación política del país del
país felicitó a Dina boluarte como nueva
presidenta de ese país suramericano de
otra parte el presidente mexicano Andrés
Manuel López Obrador rechazó los
acontecimientos señaló a las élites
económicas y políticas de Perú de haber
provocado la destitución de Castillo a
quien le ofrecieron las tierras
mexicanas como un lugar para asilarse
políticamente desde Bogotá el gobierno
colombiano hizo también un llamado al
diálogo y condenó los hechos que atentan
contra la democracia y entre tanto en
Chile lamentaron la crisis política y
también pidieron el de mecanismos
democráticos para respetar el estado de
derecho en ese país
Colombia en otros temas a 16 años de
prisión fue condenado el expresidente de
Guatemala Otto Pérez Molina así lo dio a
conocer la justicia de su país el ex
mandatario y la ex vicepresidenta Roxana
valdetti fueron declarados culpables de
los delitos de asociación ilícita y
casos de defraudación aduanera valdetti
también recibió una condena similar por
un caso de corrupción conocido como la
línea que llevó a la caída de su
gobierno en el año 2015 la decisión de
la justicia fue dada a conocer en la
jornada de hoy en una audiencia en la
que tanto Pérez como valdetti fueron
absueltos del delito de enriquecimiento
ilícito ambos habían declarado o se
habían declarado inocentes de los
señalamientos que dieron lugar
justamente a este juicio en su contra
y nos vamos ahora hasta el norte del
continente porque comenzó en Montreal en
Canadá la conferencia de Naciones Unidas
sobre biodiversidad cop 15 con el
desafío de determinar un acuerdo
histórico para salvar especies y
ecosistemas de tener una destrucción
Irreversible los delegados de más de 190
países tienen dos semanas para llegar a
ese acuerdo que puede ser una última
oportunidad para la humanidad desde la
ciudad de Montreal Carolina Villa
mediana nos da más información de esta
primera jornada de la cop 15
este miércoles 7 de diciembre comenzó en
el Palacio del Congreso de Montreal la
cop15 la Cumbre de las Naciones Unidas
para la diversidad biológica en esta
primera jornada de este importante
encuentro se realizó un trabajo más
logístico se estuvo organizando todo lo
que tiene que ver con lo que va a pasar
en los próximos días y se espera que
para este jueves en la segunda jornada
de la cop 15 ya comiencen a discutirse
aspectos claves de ese primer borrador
que ya existe del acuerdo Macro que se
espera aprobar de aquí al 19 de
diciembre fecha en que termina esta
importante cumplir hoy también
estuvieron discutiendo hace aspectos que
tienen que ver con la cop16 que se va a
celebrar en las Turquía y la cop17 que
se celebraría en una ciudad de Europa
central y del este en paralelo también
estuvieron ocurriendo algunos
acontecimientos en las afueras del
palacio del Congreso hubo algunas
manifestaciones en horas de la mañana y
a la una y media de la tarde ya la
situación estaba en total calma el
operativo policial en los alrededores
del palacio del Congreso se mantiene y
también sigue cerrada la Estación de
metro de Square Victoria que está
cerrada desde que comenzó la cop 15 Ah y
lo va a estar hasta que termine
la alcaldesa de Montreal también se
pronunció sobre el tema y dijo que
Montreal recibía a todas las voces que
quisieran expresarse y que al contrario
de criticar estas manifestaciones
consideraba que son algo que esperar y
que de alguna manera las motiva y las
celebra
pasamos a otras noticias destacadas La
mayoría demócrata en el senado de
Estados Unidos Fue consolidada gracias a
la victoria del senador Rafael warnock
frente al republicano herschell walker
en la segunda vuelta de las elecciones
de medio término en el estado de Georgia
el resultado ofrece entonces mayor
margen de maniobra al partido de
gobierno en la cámara alta veamos
una estrecha Victoria en Georgia
definida en segunda vuelta el demócrata
Rafael guarnoch ganó la reelección en la
carrera del senado con el 51,4% de los
votos y se impuso frente a republicano y
estrella del fútbol americano hershe
Walker quien obtuvo el 48,6% en Atlanta
warnuch celebró la victoria junto a su
familia y seguidores
es para mí un honor utilizar las cuatro
palabras más poderosas dichas durante
una democracia
la gente ha hablado
mientras que la cámara de representantes
quedó en manos de los republicanos con
El Triunfo de Warner los demócratas
consolidan su mayoría en el senado con
51 escaños el partido demócrata rompe
con la paridad que durante dos años los
ha hecho depender del voto de desempate
de la vicepresidenta camala Harris en su
condición de presidenta del senado
tampoco dependerán del senador demócrata
Joe manching que a pesar de hacer parte
del partido de gobierno es defensor de
los combustibles fósiles y ha bloqueado
iniciativas en materia ambiental del
presidente estadounidense Joe biden los
resultados de Georgia favorecen a biden
en su agenda legislativa hasta que
termine su primer mandato en 2024 y
representan una derrota para el ex
presidente Donald Trump quien era
cercano al candidato Derrotado
Georgia se consolida como un bastión
demócrata en el senado Pues los dos
escaños asignados para este estado se
pintaron de azul en las elecciones de
medio término junto con worknock en la
cámara alta del Congreso estará johnsoft
también demócrata las elecciones
celebradas el martes en el Estado Sureño
fueron la segunda vuelta de los comicios
de medio mandato celebrados el 8 de
noviembre en los cuales ninguno de los
dos aspirantes logró superar la Barrera
del 50% de los sufragios
esto en las noticias gracias por su
sintonía
[Música]